I was like, wait, wait a minute, I'm muted.
Hello, everyone.
Oh, my God.
Chat is cut out as well.
Oh, guys, I'm so professional.
I didn't know.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta fix chat.
Give me a sec.
You're cut off a little.
Let me fix you guys.
There we go.
Hello, everyone.
All right.
Today, I'm going to be showing you guys.
a little playlist for you guys it's like back in the day
when people make mixtapes and be like please listen to my
mixtape i made a little video i made a little like uh video
playlist and i'm like please watch my playlist please i made
this special dragoon playlist well to be fair this was my
playlist i'll be like that's funny and i save it but then
i'm like this is my dokey playlist for the dragoons so
please watch my playlist
the very important videos uh but welcome welcome welcome to
my react channel that's on twitch because i don't want to
get in trouble with youtube i'm now trying to read some
people were asking me were like oh are you gonna like
re-upload this and i'm just like i mean i can try i i don't
i I'll see what's gonna happen when I re-upload it on like
on if I like upload the VOD on like on my VOD's channel and
just see what happens to it so like you know I can try and
see that's the worst I mean it's just I have three strikes
right so like if I get striked I at least I'll have two more
strikes you know like the first track strike is just to what
happens you know at least not the main channel and
technically if you think about it that means i have two
channels so like that means i can have six strikes so like
the more channels i get the more chances i can have so like
maybe i should just create another channel in case the vaude
channels get a strike and i'll have another channel and
that's like a whole new three more strikes that i have like
the three more chances uh the five minute move the strike
leveling algorithm but welcome welcome to my twitch
everybody um it's not gonna be like a i think like not gonna
i'm not gonna be doing this a lot obviously uh it's just
like a special day today i just was i want to be like i'm
gonna show you my i can finally like show you some videos
that i've been like a while now uh because in the past we
had to like ask individually the channels to be like can can
i can i react to your videos can i show your videos and
they'll they'll either not respond or just i don't know i
guess not respond thank
you i really appreciate thank you so much i almost forgot i
was partnered on this on my twitch guys it's been a while
it's been oh i usually use my i realize when up on my twitch
channel i was like wow i was i did not set up anything on my
i did not really set up anything for like solo streams on
twitch because every time i streamed on twitch it's either
for like twitch rivals or okay it's usually for twitch
rivals so then when i was like setting everything up i was
like oh my god there's no like i don't know how to i don't
have any like By the way, I was like, wait, sorry if there's
no alerts because I'm scared of putting my alerts up right
now.
Because I don't think...
Wait, I think I did mute it.
Let me see if I can...
I'll put the Twitch alerts because I was like, oh, man, I
don't know if I have.
Let me see.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, here we go.
That's good.
Okay, that's a good sign.
All right, Twitch alerts are...
I think Twitch alerts are muted, I think.
so that's why i was a little scared because i didn't even
like adjust my twitch alerts because i was like oh no is our
alerts muted i don't know i haven't really figured it out
yet johnny lacone thank you for 20 gifted subs thank you
thank you oh my god bacon thank you for the 50 gifted subs
thank you thank you i really appreciate it guys thank you so
much I bet I'm like a twitch's favorite streamer because I
don't use up their bandwidth, but I still have subs.
So I'm like
They're like give to keep a partner.
She doesn't use up our Our bandwidth, but she still has
people giving her money on Twitch Super cost-effective yeah
we're gonna have to resize this alert holy shit all right
i'll play around with it one day and i realized i was like
oh shit even upload any like new emotes in here i'm so
fucked man i'm so but yes i don't know if like sound guy is
alive because like uh sound guy if you're here i need you to
message me on discord because your your messages are gonna
get drowned out in the Because I haven't like customized my
chat in a way that I can see I can see like I can see mods
easier.
I haven't done that yet There's a lot of things I haven't
done you guys are gonna figure it out
There there's a multiple things that I haven't done guys
Okay, anyway, anyway, also another update also another
another update for you guys you remember how i said like oh
next week i'm going to i'm going to have uh a rest week well
about that about that it might not be a rest week anymore
because i sort of like said yes to a lot of things and i
didn't i looked at my calendar and i was like oh it's this
week i was just like i mean sorry I was like, wait a minute.
They're all for, like, next week.
Oh, no.
I couldn't help it.
Okay, when you find out what they are, they're pretty
exciting.
It's pretty exciting things.
Okay, to be fair, this entire month, month of May, I'm so
fucked.
I'm actually, uh, the month of May, I sort of, I messed up a
little bit for the month of May because I said yes to a lot
of things.
and then i looked at my calendar and i was like oh at one
point there's gonna be like a back-to-back event for one of
the days and i was like oh no
but like i'm getting my name out there yahoo no rest for
content creators let's fucking go Um, okay, thank you for
the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Anyway, guys, let me show you guys the first video.
If it's like, let me know if it's like too long.
I haven't figured out my Twitch rivals team yet.
By the way, um, I saw like, so basically like, okay.
So like there's like how I figured, like I, every time I
would like so go on, like there's a Twitch rivals schedule
and I look at it every so often.
And then there's something that interests me.
I just press express interest and then like my twitch guy
would message me I was like oh we saw you express interest
for this you actually want to do it and I'll be like yeah
yeah sure like you won't be captain I'll be like oh yeah
sure and so now I have to figure out my teammates because I
haven't really figured out my teammates yet there's like not
just this twitch rivals I'm in Twitch rivals in two weeks as
well.
Because I'd be like, I'd just be like, do you want to do
this?
I'd be like, yeah, sure.
And then my DMs would be like, do you want to participate in
this tournament?
I'd be like, oh, cool.
Yeah, sure.
And then I would, do you want to do this?
Oh, that's cool.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, sure.
And then look at my calendar.
It's like tournament, tournament, event, tournament.
I'd be like, not no more yeah sure good thank you for that
right thank you thank you I really appreciate it thank you
so much yeah so now I'm like I need to stop saying yeah sure
to things and then the next day someone's gonna and then and
then I I say that to myself but then the day after they're
gonna be someone's gonna be like you want to do it up do
this like yeah sure
so it just never stops someone let me off this wild ride no
not june okay june might be a little wild but may is very
wild may is like oh this month is like oh
All right, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys the first video, guys.
All right, so I saw this and I thought it was really funny.
It's there's a new crab game that's like dark souls related.
Let me know if it's too loud or not.
Bright, colorful souls like game and thought, this is too
happy.
We need more dark and mysterious souls like games.
There just isn't enough out there.
Fair not, fellow gamer.
We have added a new feature to another crab's treasure, dark
souls like mode.
Yeah, because it's too happy.
I should sort of want and replace it with I was sort of like
I've been wanting to play this game for a bit Because like
it's basically like a happier version of Dark Souls So and
you play like a cry you play a crab so
So so it's just it's just a happier version of Dark Souls
I've been wanting to try out for a bit because like it looks
you know, not depressing anyway dark color scheme does krill
appear too happy let's remove that sparkle in his eyes and
determination for adventure in dark souls like mode krill
will become depressed oh look at him not a hope inside are
you feeling it now instagram dark souls like mode unlocks a
new costume you might recognize it for redacted redacted
copyright strike redacted this costume will hide krill's
defeated face so we're gonna mod that dark souls like mode
also turns all levels into a poison swamp because it's not a
real souls like game without one look at that poisony
goodness we also added arnold londo okay i got okay i got
this ad on my shorts i was like is that markiplier but okay
but then like the okay okay i just you guys to know i got
this ad while scrolling through YouTube shorts and
and like the plot twist is that not only is that character
based off of Markiplier but it's for Markiplier and like
basically I wouldn't get any closer if I were you I'm not
saying by the way if anybody wants to download this game
feel free I was just I was like wait this is like It's a
dating sim But like instead of dating like The human
versions of them You're dating the Animals But like They're
not the thing is The thing is they're not Like they're
actual animals Like it's not even furry anymore they're
actually animals and i was like oh this is
i was just like wait a minute there's something anyway it's
called blush blush um can somebody please play this game for
me and then report back report back can can someone play
this game and report back to me um oh yeah also i really
want to show you guys this video why would you do that i
want to show you guys this one this has been like this list
rent free in my mind sometimes this video
this is one of my favorite covers guys
This was me four years ago.
Yay!
Oh, yeah, I should carry this, so I'll cut it.
I love SpongeBob Vocaloid.
You guys, there's one with, like, Reaper from Overwatch.
And then there's one, there's one, there's so many of
SpongeBob, and then there's like Cartman Vocaloids too.
I listened to this cover like once a year.
It's not just me!
It was not AI!
It's Vocaloid!
It's different!
Uncultured swine!
I don't know.
Look at him go!
Look at Squidward go!
Look at the secret!
I don't know.
Kill the solid sources of videos.
Damn!
Okay.
SpongeBob is Squidward.
Vocaloid walked.
So like, what was it?
The fucking AI rap covers could run.
I don't know.
Oh, Squidward, go.
He's so kawaii.
Oh my god, there's the presidential covers!
Wait, you're so right!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, okay.
I don't know, you guys...
Okay, I need to...
Oh my god, Plankton!
Look at him go!
You guys can't see him.
He's over there on the right.
I'm covering him up.
Have you guys seen the presidential covers?
Um...
The A.I saw it.
Go, Plains, and Go.
Okay, but like, this is like, okay, I'll just say, okay, I
need to show you guys the OG.
I need you guys, I need to show you guys the OG.
We're at the OG MMD, the rabbit hole.
I think it's this one.
It has to be this one, right?
This has to be like, I think this is the OG.
This is the rabbit hole of where I go.
Oh my gosh, where I found this.
It just was seven years ago, by the way.
Look at him go, so beautiful.
He's so kawaii.
This was my rabbit hole.
I am watching.
My Reaper can't be this kawaii.
Yo, thank you for the 150s.
Thank you, thank you.
Slay!
Reaper, Slay!
My god!
Speaking of this, okay, no, no, no, no, no, speaking of
this, have you guys heard of the Toons Drag Race?
Wait, Toons of Drag Race.
Have you guys seen that?
Oh, my God, wait.
Okay, I think it's this one.
What was it?
Who is all?
Wait, who is Cartoon's Drag Race?
Okay, that, like, popped up on my Twitter feed.
And I...
It's so fucking stupid.
the first season of cartoons drag races okay no does anyone
have the actual youtube video it's on tick tock so like
nobody has the actual car video please re-upload it on
please i'm making making youtube channel okay drag race
cartoons all right let me see i could find it No guys I
can't react to it because nobody no he didn't make a YouTube
channel He didn't make it We're safe.
No, it's so funny though You don't understand also here's
one with with our boys
Oh my oh
my god look at his legs
Look it's soldiers fucking you wish you that's why we call
him legs guys This is exactly why we call him legs
This is my rabbit hole overwatch MMDs other people other
people they other people they watch the overwatch they watch
overwatch different overwatch videos I watch this
they go to a different site for their overwatch videos I
just watch overwatch Dee
Oh my god For all that running though It paid off for
Soldier My whole run Goes to another All I'm saying Is that
Okay Okay Let me oh, and then there's this one
Oh, here's a Cartman version Let's see I'm trying to find
the Cartman version here.
Yeah, here's a Cartman AI
They did like I found I wanted a rabbit hole of these covers
where like, they did like various, various like cartoon
characters.
Let me tell you all of that, my guy.
Speaking in around a somewhat slight.
Every now and then, I want to try.
It's so good!
Something getting sounded blind in the eyes.
Jotting in a feeling, choking the mind.
Counting all the raiders out the skies.
Bro, he's a natural singer.
Bumping into hate, I'll wash away.
Something where it is you hide the pain.
Smiling, no, I tell gracefully.
it's a peter there's a lot of them by the way it's not just
karmic there's a peter oh my god there's a peter griffin one
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait let me show you guys
the peter griffin one peter griffin um ai uh oh my god it
was it was a steven universe song
Bro AI goes hard I was fine With the men Who would come into
her life Now and again Bro, why do people like use AI
unethically?
Why can't we do meme shit like this?
Like we're Bro!
Why can't we just do fun stuff?
Why did people have to ruin it?
It's so good!
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
and she chose you and she loved you and she's gone it's over
isn't why can't i move on more and more like a stewie
fucking guy attention out in daylight my potential bold
precise experimental who am i now in this world
Lois, Peter.
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
You won and she chose you and she loved you and she's gone.
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
Sorry, I went into a rabbit hole of...
I'm going through so many different rabbit holes right now.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm getting off track.
Anyway, back to my playlist.
Back to my...
Anyway, back to the playlist that I fucking made for you
guys.
Guess anyway, why?
I'm showing you guys all the fun videos I wanted to show
you.
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
All right, to be fair, I'll give you guys some normal
videos.
That wasn't the playlist.
No, no, no, no.
These are, like, videos I just went, I was like, oh, my God.
I want to, oh, my God, I forgot about these videos, too.
Anyway, here are, like, actual normal videos that I watched,
by the way.
Here are some actual normal videos.
Okay, I'm going to recommend you guys a channel that I've
actually, like, really liked to watch.
ever so often and it's like a cooking channel but um but
like he does like cookbook reviews but he does like gamer
cookbook reviews and it's like really interesting because
like all I always think like who buy these types of
cookbooks you know like those types of cookbooks where it's
like gamer gaming or anime or like TV show inspired and like
he does like those like reviews of those cookbooks because I
always wonder who buys these like who the fuck you know like
oh families visiting let me make a let me make an assassin's
creed meal inspired like like dinner or so yes it's me so
hungry I just finished binging the fallout TV show okay this
is like actually I thought it really captured the unique
post-apocalyptic flavor of the games and it got me really
nostalgic I really he does like updates honestly i'm
surprised he only has 150k subscribers because like i
actually really enjoy uh watching his his videos and stuff
so like so he has like all these like he does like cookbook
reviews and stuff and be like bob's burgers the sonic
cookbook and like oh like neopets cookbook uh the rick and
morty let's watch the rick and morty one uh hey put me over
Boom, big reveal.
I turned myself into a pickle.
I'm pickle miso.
Why did I turn myself into a pickle?
You gotta have a high enough IQ to understand this.
Well, I hear Rick and Morty might be needing a new voice
actor.
So think of this as my audition.
Come on, Cartoon Network.
If you had any...
All right, we're gonna skip this.
This is a little cringe.
We're taking a look at Rick and Morty, a picture cookbook by
August Craig and James Assel.
This book takes us along Rick and Morty's adventure through
space and time with a focus on the funky alien foods they
come across along the way.
I really dig the way they presented this cookbook, basically
for Morty's home economics school project, he decided to put
together a cookbook of his family's favorite recipes.
Rick doesn't want Morty wasting his time on this silly
school project since they got to go on adventures, so what
does he do?
Rick fills up the rest of the book itself.
It's so interesting because like some of the cookbooks,
they're like really well designed with like pictures of the
food.
Just like the show, it's crazy and wacky and it feels like
there's something fun to expect after every page turn.
I really love the layout of the book.
I think it's the perfect balance of text and imagery, lots
of fun flavor text to read, and very close in tone to the
dark humor of the show.
There are no F-bombs or anything, but there are some mature
leading jokes in there that's very on brand.
I also really like how the recipe pages are littered with
illustrations and even screenshots from the show.
And the screenshots are usually lifted from the same episode
that the recipe is inspired by, which is a neat addition.
The food photos are awesome as I've always wanted to have a
little bits.
Some photos have lab equipment in the background to make
them look like a part of Rick's lab.
And some photos have the characters interacting with the
food.
The abundant illustrations and attention to detail really
makes this one of the most thematic and most fun cookbooks
to look at.
Not all recipes have photos, but in this case, I don't even
mind because there's so much other good content to
supplement it.
The recipes themselves are based off of food for the show or
are inspired by references in the show.
with names thrown just because like they really tried to
draw it's actually interesting he also shows majority of the
book so like you know i don't have to like actually you know
you know it's like some people just like oh he's just like
one or two pages but he shows majority of books so i don't
actually have to buy the book i can just like pause the
video from the rick and morty now we can't do rick and morty
food without paying tribute to the iconic i just pause the
video inspired a bunch of merch including this one so to
make pickle rick's transformation i always find it really
interesting we're gonna skip a lot but then he usually does
like he cooks all of it and he cooks like he um he makes
fans pick three rep recipes that he he's gonna cook in the
cookbook and then um and then like he does three and then he
gives obviously he gives his ratings also he's not like a
professional cook or anything he's just some like regular
guy that just wants a like that just you know he's just like
an amateur cook he's just like me he's just like you so it's
like anybody can cook type dia um it's really interesting
because like you know he was like obviously like if he can
make it like that means i can make it technically and uh and
then he gives like a review and be like which one which one
is good or not and the story point ones are just much less
of a hassle you know but if you're really looking to make
homemade ones then this is a pretty solid i like how it's
green screen so you don't see the pickle but these chili
dogs are the ones i've been eyeing up they just some guy
yeah he's just some guy taste test with flying colors this
is pretty dang delicious so yeah this is honestly like one
this is like one of my favorite channels to watch just like
oh my god i was watching the one piece one and then holy
shit why is that curry blue
fuck it's blue and then he made the bacon pancakes right
here i watch i watched that one and then there's the uh okay
there's one that i saw i was like really bring along all
your hopes and dreams look at this corn beef is such an
underrated it's the one piece turkey more in fried rice so
yeah if you like it's the one piece turkey it looks so okay
this looks actually look so fucking good though like look at
that to wrap my mouth around this thing it's the one piece
turkey i got the ground meat coating in a bit of the
hard-boiled that looks so good the meat was okay but the
meat stick a little dry for my second bite i tried to get
more of the drumstick meat which was way more moist and
tasted a lot don't worry he like has his recipe for it what
the fuck there's an egg inside i already forgot there was an
egg inside how do you make that don't worry just subscribe
to me so hungry the best part is that he tells the recipe in
the video so you actually don't have to buy the book like
you can just follow the recipe in this video which is the
but if you really want to support if you want to support the
cook the publisher you should buy the book but
but like you know if you really want to support the
publisher you could also buy the book but like the best part
is that you know he gives like a step-by-step guide in the
video itself so like i don't have to worry about like trying
to figure out the recipe loose more seasoning to the meat
maybe marinate the drumstick oh my god i'm so hungry now
looking at this see i think it's this one right no that's
the meat on the bone here when sanji joined the crew on the
bone this version of meat on the bone isn't as simple as you
think though because there's a whole egg inside this recipe
is gonna need four chicken drumsticks apparently we're
supposed to make tulips oh it was a turkey it's a chicken so
small that it's kind of hard to make sense out of it but i
think i figured it out so you take your scissors and start
at the handle end stick it under the skin and cut up to the
meat cutting as close to the bone as possible why did you
start with food videos the other sides of the no we started
off with like kind of inside out we definitely did not start
with food videos or a meat salad or a meat upside down
umbrella so that you'll have the meat exposed i'm sorry to
all the vegans and vegetarians that are watching this then
you're gonna take a quarter cup of breadcrumbs and soak it
in three tablespoons of milk that much work to be honest you
just cut a chicken in a bowl mixed together 18 ounces of 500
grams of ground chicken with one teaspoon of salt but not
the vocal like you're expecting together and then mix in the
milky bread crumbs and knead it again.
Now to assemble the drumsticks, you're going to need one
hard-boiled egg per chicken drumstick.
Take the layers of meat and grate it around a hard ball
there.
I see.
Then oil your hands and then take the meat mixture and cover
the drumstick and egg so it looks like a chicken woman a
chicken.
Just like in the anime.
When everything is assembled, bake the drumsticks in the
oven at 400 degrees Fahrenheit for 15 to 20 minutes.
raise the 10th to 450 and then broil it for another 5 to 10
minutes to give it that nice brown color which is what i did
when done you should have four nice if i wasn't so lazy i'd
do this god damn it if i wasn't a streamer i'd do this but
yeah this is like one of my favorite channels that like i
i'm really happy whenever whenever they like uh whenever
they have like new episodes I always, like, was like, ooh,
time to watch.
But I feel like he's so high effort.
Like, his, the stuff he does, and, like, his, like, video
production, it's so high effort for, like, 150k subscribers.
You guys should check him out.
He's actually, I feel like he's very underrated.
Also, here's one of my favorite videos.
I talked about it before, but I wanted to show you guys,
because I couldn't show it on YouTube.
them draw lola bunny with fewer sexual features so they
wouldn't be horny and reduce your blood flow to make you a
millisecond slower is it slow enough for me to kill iris
remember when you were making out with your first girlfriend
it was me barry right as she touched your leg it was me
barry i jerked you off at super speed so it'd seem like you
nutted at just a woman's touch sorry i had to
It was me, Barry.
It was honestly one of my favorite reverse flash, reverse
flash lines.
It's a classic.
It's such a classic.
Oh my god.
So my favorite like DC animator slash, okay, she does like
Team Fortress 2 animations too.
Spineapples.
I don't know if you guys know Spineapples, but like I
fucking love her animations and like her like team fortress
too and like uh her team fortress too and dc animations are
so good like this one
hello sponapples what is this it's a meme batman i don't
understand what do you not understand well you see people
usually only play on one console but both these women are so
but they aren't consoles it's a classic they're wearing half
the console logos where are you some kind of furry you're
the one here wearing an animal suit it's true it's true i
think batman's a furry because why else would he dress up as
a bat checkmate but you guys should check out spawn apples
he's like they're one of my favorite uh they're one of my
favorite like animators they're Shit, some of their
animations are like what is it like four plus four plus
years ago.
Oh my god to this rap the rap battle the spy rap
Do you guys know the spy rap the one with spy versus tracy
Trust to the night no clue is that the disguise with a
classy suit and tie who will look good at your funeral It's
time to murder this track you find a knife in its back got
the equipment watch me break it saw me die I'm a man of many
faces infiltrated plenty bases stole your intel what a rush
even though Sombra oh wait what was it?
Scout versus tracer was the the the OG rap Oh my god, okay
guys guys guys OG OG raps scout it's not cringe it was not
cringe Cringe it's actually so good back when like everyone
fucking did rap battles every Like you know how like rap
battles like rap battles of history like pioneered.
Okay, they didn't pioneer rap battles like like it was there
for a while But it's not cringe They were so good But like
it made rap battles like with like What's the word with like
pop culture really popular so then people did like parodies
with uh uh they did parody oh my god it's still going
they're so old now like they did like parodies with like
games and like anime and stuff like that i fucking bro i
love the scout versus tracer scout versus tracer was really
good from jt oh my god machinima
i actually have the song in my fucking playlist it's not
cringe this was six years ago it was like it's history we
We're part of history!
You don't...
Oh yeah, we don't miss Machima.
It's so cringe!
Oh my god, it actually slaps!
It's just the animations old!
It was six years ago!
It's not cringe!
Die!
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
Somebody said that they nerfed Tracer's ass, but like, it
never, it didn't really change that much, to be fair.
I feel like, okay, wait.
Samba and Spy was good too.
Guys, I swear!
You guys just don't understand!
Today's rat battle is brought to you.
It's nine!
I should know.
I killed it.
Who's that?
Trust to the nines.
They're so good at rapping!
It's not a face.
It's not even super!
This was literally sick!
Six years ago!
Wait, there's Mercy versus Medic?
I've never seen the Mercy versus Medic one.
What's the Mercy versus Medic?
They did so many.
God damn, the animation is so dated.
It's time for your prognosis, the doctor is in.
Heroes never die, but you're not one of them.
I arrive on swift wings like a bird in a hurry If you have
an emergency, get blood out to Mercy I may have a halo, but
I am no angel With my damage buffs, I can make your life
better Where's Medic?
I don't care about Mercy Whoa!
Okay, not gonna lie, the voice acting for this is pretty
good
Okay, this one's pretty bad, I'll admit This one was pretty
bad
I'll give you guys that That one was pretty bad
Okay, but did you guys know Like the TF2 Like cast Cast
actually did like a song cover together I saved it because I
was like Whoa, that's a Team Forge's 2 voice actors Okay,
where is it?
I saved a video too It's called The Sandwich Blues They
actually did like Yeah, they did This was like a month ago,
last month.
Walk up this morning.
The sandwich was gone.
Didn't leave no note.
Nothing to go on.
Looked under the covers.
Under the sheet.
Now Heavy's brokenhearted.
He's got nothing to eat.
We got the sandwich blues.
We're down again our soul.
Yeah, they're doing like song coverage now, which I thought
was funny.
We're down again our soul.
oh god they're so old yeah i think they're like in their 50s
or 60s now or they have to be in 60s where are we gonna have
a plan where we gonna look in so many places we could write
a book those actors are so talented i can only do like three
voices child no and this
We got a sandwich blues.
Things are taking control.
This can't be happening.
Heavy is out of control.
Please stop it, Heavy.
You met a mysterious woman.
Oh yeah, this boy, the...
How's it?
What's her name?
The announcer?
The announcer and Sniper, like, married Ira.
She's met us in a bar.
But we ain't got no sandwich.
We only got a car We got a sandwich blues And then Our soul
We got a sandwich blues Don't need to take a pole If we
don't find it soon Having gone to eat a throne Yeah they're
doing like They're doing like music covers now together
Which I thought was really cute cogitated maybe it's a curse
edmund's intimidating she's nobody's nerd if we don't find
the sandwich hair is gonna be our hurts we got the sandwich
blues way down in our soul it's still the sandwich blues put
it on a scroll all right guys now we're gonna see something
really cursed i need to show you guys this video shabby
traps I'm sure no one will be creeped out by this this
popped up I like look it's the this boss it's the Boston dog
look it is who don't know they're gonna create something
very special so I bought a robotic dog this video is brought
to you by Squarespace no not this video
so what so they're gonna make something beautiful today with
Furby actually gonna turn our robot into a Furby well we
know someone who has a lot of experience 3d printing Furby
projects I never like these masks probably want that mask
holy shit that's terrifying that's fucking terrifying by the
way I've I've never watched the full video.
I only watched like the final product.
So I actually don't know what it is.
I don't know how they made this.
Our first step was to 3D scan the robot and send it to him
so he could accurately model the Furby parts for it.
I'm collecting so many points of data.
Now I'm going to angle down and kind of get some of the
nooks and crannies.
Show me your crannies.
All right.
Evan's zooming in on his butt.
Well good posing.
So we just got an update from Austin.
He has a few different mockups of different forms.
wait different forms there's more than one when we were
originally talking about this idea Evan was showing like see
if we can try to put the the Furby's face like directly over
the front of it oh god that's that's more terrifying maybe
than what it was what it came to be the best ones that I
could think of and included like some of the pros and cons
and I think we've got yes I'm ready so the first option oh
god oh no i'm just gonna say this up front it's possible
that these mock-ups might be too good i know that's really
good glorious heights here we go we'll start with the pros
he's huggable yes he's huggable like you hugged this baby i
thought about like baby doll arm sort of thing yeah i've got
mixed feelings yeah there's plenty of room for the
electronics cons It might just look like it's a Furby
sitting on a dog's head attachment points is another thing
that we might need to figure out Yeah, we want to make sure
it's not top heavy and toppling right?
Well, it's the spider Oh Oh No Oh, I'm so uncomfortable
Arachno Furby Arachno Furby Once again, it could look like a
Furby is riding the back of a dog We could have people
commenting how it doesn't actually have six legs Well
spiders have eight legs, so we'd have a lot of legs.
So this is the last one.
I call this one Mr. Nodak What is that?
Oh God.
It looks like a primate Furby Uses less material.
Yeah, very human-like.
It's so cool.
I was like, that looks so cool though.
Look, think of the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
But the original thing that brought up this whole issue was
the front sensors.
Yeah.
Yes.
It might be okay, but we could just avoid the whole worry by
going with the Centaur, you know?
Right.
I mean, even though Mr. No-neck looks amazing, and that was
actually one of my original visions, I'm most curious about
Centaur.
What about you?
I am also, I think, leaning towards Centaur.
I feel like it gives us a little bit more wiggle room in
terms of electronics.
And honestly, I thought it would be much more cursed feeling
to me, but he almost feels like a llama.
Like he's just got a really long hand.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
He looks so huggable.
To be fair you compared this with the other two that we saw
like this looks in between oh, it's so cute now This looks
actually cute compared to the other ones that we saw Like it
actually makes it look good I mean compared to the fucking
spider It's a no-neck come on So we thought we'd add a pop
of color with pink inspired by the original gray and pink
furby we bought i had a furby i had the furby and those
little dog ones little dog pets it's on sale it's always on
sale and then the how is it the cat the cat ones as well no
neck was not cute no i don't know what you guys are thinking
no neck was not cute it looks like a monkey with a furby
attached to his head we can just save it right yeah
oh for real friends yes That's a pretty good match.
Yeah, it's a good match for the gray.
You combine that with the pink.
I feel like it's very Furby-esque.
That's very Furby-esque.
We did it baby.
He's gonna be so hairy.
How to attach all this fur to our- I like how they're giving
us a tutorial on making our very own Furby.
So Furby core.
You cover that with tape.
And then you sharpie over the tape, cut out your pattern,
and then make that in fabric.
Yeah.
Let's see how this works.
any like and i think the good news okay so i need you guys
to know these costs like what is it it costs like more than
30 grand right the boston robots on its own yeah any like
super rich dragoons want to make a dragoon version of a
dragon version oh like 10k oh it's less now it used to be
like crazy expensive when they first launched oh it's a
thousand six hundred now wait that's a see ya any like
engineer dragoons any engineer dragoons that can make this
oh yeah because it's like mass produced now when it first
came out it was like crazy fucking expensive cut it she
ripped it which maybe is best practice for this type of
fabric but she had to use so much effort she was like hold
on i need to chug this real quick i couldn't buy one but i'm
not an engineer i can't make my own dragoon version of this
moved on to other one and i was like can i help like I don't
know what I didn't know what to do to like be helpful, but
she was just just oh, it's not from Boston Dynamics It's a
bootleg
Can copy your homework let me change it up a little bit
Okay, let's take a little little dress for sure.
Oh, yeah, oh this cuts fine I don't know why she didn't cut
it.
They just use some heavy freaking duty scissors.
They have every freaking duty scissors.
It's it's Joann's Either way, I was rooting for her the
whole time.
Can I see that cross-section?
And then the short...
So I'm going to skip the...
I'm going to skip the fur part.
Oh my god.
What?
Look at it?
That's kind of glorious.
Do you want to do the rest of the leg and see what it looks
like?
Oh, they're like plastic wrapping it so the fur doesn't come
off.
Oh, or like getting the...
Oh, they're getting like the pattern.
I see there you go there you go Can you imagine it We're
skipping the fur part of the furby Oh my god It looks so
good We did such a good job It actually looks so good Oh my
god Yeah I was gonna say the Boston 9 hours When they're
crazy expensive Showing like at the elbow and stuff It
doesn't bother me at all Like here it is But you zoom out
You don't even notice that Yeah Oh Hey thank you for the
Thank you for the tier 1 set Thank you See it doesn't look
that fucked up.
He's just getting a fur.
When we started this project, I really had no clue how we
were going to make it happen.
It doesn't look that bad, guys.
I'm looking at this.
I'll tell you guys the end result looks so cute.
We're doing it.
We don't need any fast patterns or anything like that.
But we are winging it and it's working.
Okay.
Can you walk without the fur getting caught in the joints?
I was not smart enough to do this.
Maybe we check.
Maybe we check after the walk.
streams just making like verbi abominations oh my gosh i'm
getting done oh yeah he's moving oh he's moving and grooving
that's so cute this is my new pet i remember like when the
boston dynamics like released the first video the dog and
all they did was just push it around and like hit it it No!
Can we know a little bit of what we're getting?
But we haven't seen what it looks like.
They stop!
Is that a note?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Austin.
The exhilarating Furbot instruction manual.
Oh my gosh!
Look at this!
This is so fantastic!
First thing I see is this adorable thing.
Yeah, you guys are going to see an even more adorable thing
later.
Oh my god, they gave me this.
in it for a second.
No, I don't get paid!
Squarespace doesn't sponsor this?
Guys, no, don't type that URL.
Instead type the gamer subs way.
Don't type this URL.
Okay, step one.
Insert both support arms into the main support base and
tighten both- We don't get paid.
Step two, slide battery power bank into dedicated slot on
backup quadruped.
Wrap, buckle, and tighten down both support straps around
the cargo bed robot.
I'll pay somebody to follow these instructions.
Okay, place Furby Body on Main Support Base, aligning with
Magnus.
Make a Dragoon version of this.
I will pay you, I will pay Dragoon to make a Dragoon version
of this.
I can see.
There's no fur.
Yeah, it's just like the bones.
I can see the mouth through there.
Where's your Squarespace sponsorship?
I don't know Squarespace.
Where is my Squarespace sponsorship?
That's asleep right now.
Oh, this is...
And then have it run around conventions and just terrorize
people.
Oh, God.
I don't like...
I think he looks worse with the eyes closed.
Oh, I hate that.
I don't like that.
I think it's, like, really bad because he doesn't even have
fur.
It's like a skinned Furby.
Let's power it up.
God, save us all.
That's awful.
Maverick, thank you for the 25k in the sauce.
Thank you.
He's like awakening as he's being operated on.
Like his anesthesia is lifting.
Oh my gosh.
Let's open the box.
Okay, let's open this last box.
I hate this abomination.
That's so sweet.
Oh my god!
Oh, so cute!
They made pens dispenser as a gift.
Stop looking at me.
Just like chalk.
Okay, back to it.
Back to it.
Let's make it say something.
Ready?
Yeah.
Doof, doof, doof.
Doof, come on.
I'm moving with the words.
It's getting it.
Subscribe, subscribe to heaven.
Okay, look, for all the...
I'm saying, all I'm saying, Dragoons, I'll pay someone to
make a Dragoon equivalent version of this, and then I'll
want it to run around different conventions and be like,
subscribe to dokeybirding.
Yeah, I wanted to just to start chilling me I I will pay a
smart engineering dragon to do this I will I will do it I
think I think the investment the investment goes a long way
A large switch on the back of the Furbot.
If Curiosity got the best of you, you may have found that
no, it's not a power switch to the Furbot.
The switch toggles cursed mode.
Curse mode.
The effects of this mode will become immediately obvious
upon toggling the switch while the Furbot is powered on.
I'm so tempted to press it.
I know, me too.
Me too, I want to press it, but I feel like we need to
finish him first.
Yeah, no.
And then see what can be more cursed than he already is.
He's rising.
Oh!
The Texas!
The curse of Irby.
Oh my god.
This is everything that I hope for.
I said thank you for the Twitch prize.
Wait, is that even Chris mode?
Is it Chris mode yet?
I'm ready.
Oh yeah, they're gonna resonate.
Are you gonna put fur on it now?
Help.
Oh my gosh.
They're like mummifying it.
It's almost like they're mummifying the furby.
That's 3D printed some of yours.
Can you see me?
I can see you.
It's evolving in real time.
It's getting so dusty.
I seriously think I'm more used to cat hair being on me Like
this is normal I don't know
It's like more fur than robotics if you think about it Oh
god his neck is so long Guys don't look yet There's another
child that I really like to watch That does like that does
like Repurposing like Halloween decorations
Oh my god, look at his last try.
Oh my god, you guys!
It's everything I wanted.
And more.
Not to pat ourselves on the back, but like, we did a really
good job.
Oh my god!
He's outside!
He is very cursed, but he can still move around, but he's
got that Kirby vibe.
There you go!
Bro, he's better than a real dog!
Because he could actually talk!
You'd be like, what?
Doki, what happened to Doki Amberdoge?
And then...
Oh!
No, he's getting eggs!
That was a lot of our new friends introduced themselves.
Hello, Evan.
How going?
Hello, Coco.
Bring me to life.
With good,
I am no longer well
for now.
Coco seems like a nice guy.
So I think he was ready to be introduced to the world.
What do you think?
He seems safe.
Yeah.
Safe.
Coco seems like a nice guy.
Oh, my God.
Seeing him move like that is so scary.
Oh, my God, he's like shaking his hips.
I'm sure it won't be bad.
Oh, yeah.
We never got to see evil mode.
I never got to see evil mode.
Evan's pushing the button.
What's evil mode?
What does it look like?
Oh, I don't like...
Oh, I don't like evil.
Oh!
I don't like evil mode.
Imagine just having this running around during Halloween.
Oh!
Oh, no.
It, like, looks towards me.
Can I beat?
Thank you for the tier one song.
Thank you.
No!
Okay, back in normal mode.
Shall we take him out?
Let's take him out.
I'm sure no one will be creeped out by this.
Okay, so I watched the ending.
I skipped all the...
I skipped, like, how to make it, but I watched the ending of
this.
Taking it out for a walk.
I didn't even know about the curse mode.
I love how they gave Coco a dog tag and a collar.
And it's named Coco!
The dog tag is named Coco!
Oh!
No!
Oh god it's so...
The poor dog!
She's like a new poster, correct?
Look at this.
Look at the usual.
Let's say the least.
And then look at the eyes.
That is so rat.
That is awesome.
That is so cool.
He's like, ah!
He's a propaganda dog.
Yeah.
So rat.
Are you gonna like me?
I know you have.
He likes it.
It's like a real dog.
This guy hasn't infected with internet yet.
Be used later for protection and security when they put a
gun attached to it.
The new protection.
Oh my god, look!
He's picking up the bus!
It's like a real dog!
Isn't it a beautiful thing?
family thanks again to austin so beautiful but yeah anyway i
all i'm all i'm saying guys all i'm saying is i will 100
invest in this if any very smart engineer goons out there
make a dragon equivalent of this i will invest a lot of
money this is a tick tock video i saw
I feel like this is what's worse like
This is a lot worse.
Oh, look at this!
It's hard to play piano Look at this
Oh my god
I bet you the I bet you the Furby dog can learn piano faster
than this cat It's so cute look he's learning it's burning
expanding eat bobo he's playing on his own that's so cute
anyway i i felt like you guys needed that to we needed the
cleanser for that also i was like watching people make like
school lunches Okay, I was watching somebody watch the
school lunch shit, but I've also like watched like actual
parents making school lunches And I'm just like holy shit
the amount of effort and time like look at this We're gonna
watch somebody reacting to I'll get the actual channel so we
don't react to the person reacting
But I was like looking at it making school lunches and i'm
like jesus oh my god she does so much too re-accepted like
look at this oh my god whoops i forgot to put in a playlist
like she has like there's like different stuff like bath
times and like she does like diy is for like her daughter
and stuff like that and i'm like oh my god that's like so
much effort Buy stuff.
Okay, wait, let me show you guys.
Alright, where's my playlist?
Where's my liked videos?
There it is.
Alright, here.
I was like, the commitment to this.
Ugh.
She has a whole drawer for, like, her kid.
Like, this is just dedicated to making food for her
children.
What a mom.
Like, she has, like, like, there's, like, There's a lot of
these channels of, like, moms making school lunches, or,
like, just, like, lunch and dinner for their children.
And, like, one of the moms, like, showed their fucking
collection of cookie cutters.
It was actually crazy.
They had, like, they had, like, oh, I think, like, 100
cookie cutters for different themes.
Like, the budget for this?
Not gonna lie.
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say.
Uh, this is...
so fucked up for me to say but like i feel like she could
buy healthier foods for their child um like that's tastier
for like one third of the price of all this stuff oh she has
like just like look because you need two cookie cutters And
then look at all this!
Oh my god, that's a lot of seasoning.
Oh my god.
Like, she has, like, a snack drawer, too.
And then, like, a container for cheeses?
Anyway, she does, like, but it's crazy.
She's, like, so dedicated to her child.
Because...
Because she made, like, her own bakery for her child.
like oh my god that we often go to she's so creative
surprise her by giving her a french bakery i decided that i
was going to at least attempt to make many of the baked
goods by hand even though i don't know how to sew after many
failed attempts she doesn't know how to sew but look at what
she made one night at one o'clock in the morning when i
finished my first felt macaroon it was in that moment that i
was overcome with emotion even though i was making all of
this for my daughter my inner child was telling me thank you
for being the mother that i never had i derive so i'm like
oh my god i want a mini bakery i want a baby oh my god stay
tuned for the final review this look at this what the this
child gets her own mini bakery oh my god i want to be this
fucking parent's child look at this this crease of mommy
issues it's not fair and then there's for my daughter's
lunch today we are doing a deconstructed what the fuck
oh look look at all these cookie cutters that's what i'm
saying there's another i actually have i actually subscribe
to this other mom channel that makes lunches for their kids
and like it's more than this she has so many cookie cutters
it's actually crazy this lunchbox is perfect for this meal
because it contains a thermos compartment that will keep the
noodles warm first up are turkey dogs broccoli and a pitted
boiled egg and the cutest bottle of soy Definitely an only
child Oh no for real no she is definitely And of course our
spoon and fork I know some of y'all love to drag my lunchbox
ideas Do you see that mini Heinz?
Is that mini Heinz?
What is that?
Like a sword It's so tiny They come in that size To drag my
lunchbox ideas so for clarification This is a loose
interpretation of a ramen bowl not to be taken literally my
harshest critic so if she loves it that's oh my god she no
no you are not using her amazon like
anyway so there's like these are the things i watch by the
way i don't like critique it as harsh as this it's just like
i'm just watching it i was like oh my god like here i am
ordering uber eats while she makes a fucking like mona lisa
lunch for her child uh no pre-average
All right, well, here's this other one I want to show you
guys.
Oh, look at this.
Okay, okay, look at it.
Where is it?
There was like, did you guys know?
Okay, at one point, my algorithm was filled with like Lego
builders.
And like, there was like this, apparently there's like
custom Lego blocks.
Where is it?
I was, I got recommended some like custom Legos.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, wait, here you go.
$211 worth of custom cursed Lego parts, which are the
weirdest in the world.
Let's find out what's inside.
The first item is a custom Walter White from Breaking Bad.
Walter comes with, of course, some nice blue candy, and he
snubbed those over.
I looked at the website and like...
In this bag, we have an Amazon Prime box and a custom
military helmet.
I also got this very strange long head with lots of pieces
around the head.
I actually sort of went the long heads.
I don't know what these guys are, but they look funny
enough.
Here we have this guy.
Look at this tiny face!
I've also got this weird double-faced head.
And also this drunken long clown face.
I also bought this calculator with a hidden message when you
flip it upside down.
Too bad I can't read.
Here's this cracked phone.
A US passport.
A bounce trap.
I also got this oddly chilled sock monkey.
A snack people were eating for some reason.
Here's a magic eight ball.
Here we have an innocent videotape.
Lastly, a pouch of blood.
It's so cool.
What the fuck?
Guys, there's like this channel.
There's like this channel.
What's that keep going?
Anyway, anyway, so there's like this channel, by the way,
there's like this channel, I didn't watch the ending of
that, I just need you guys to know, I just saw the star
scream and I thought that was cool, I didn't watch the
ending, I did, I, okay, so like, there's, like, these random
russian channels i don't know if it's like i can't tell if
it's deep fake or not but like i think it's deep fake
because people are like debating debating it in comments and
uh oh sorry megatron people were debating about it in in
like comments whether or not these are like deep fakes or or
actual um or like actual uh uh uh like what's it how is it
called double gangers um but like there's like three of them
like four of them there's one of like leo there's there's
one with the wednesday girl actor the other one was what's
your name the barbie actress and then the charlie and the
chocolate factory factory actor but it's actually so crazy
they're all have the same name too and it's like some
russian some like Russian channels.
Let me check.
I'll show you guys.
It's actually crazy.
I was like, what the fuck?
Um, let's see.
I'm pretty sure it's deep fake.
I think it's deep fake, but like, they have like, they have
several.
It's actually crazy.
They have like so many different channels.
Yeah, it says fake, but like people don't know if it's like
actors, like that just looked like them or or like actually
uh if they're actually just like deep fakes because like
look at this okay not like this i keep forgetting to like
the videos because i did the format like that
like look this has to be deep fake right right that's deep
fake right There has to be deep fake, right?
I can't tell.
It's so good.
It's actually great.
Technology is like crazy now.
It's so hard to tell these days if it's deep fake or not.
What is this?
Now I'm scared.
I love this.
I love this YouTuber.
I love this guy.
This guy that makes like crazy.
these shit for his figures.
Oh my god.
You guys should check him out.
Um, Yoshi Channel.
This guy's insane.
Look at him go.
Like, look at that.
It's actually insane.
He's so talented.
I was, like, watching a lot of his videos of him, like,
making, like, props for his figures.
Like, what the fuck?
Look, he made He made that with his hands.
What the hell?
What the?
Holy shit.
It's like survival game crafting.
Like he made all of this.
It's actually insane that he's able to make that.
Okay, wait.
Let me show you his channel.
It's actually, I like love his work.
I recently discovered his stuff.
But like there's like a slower version of it.
but he does like um figure mods and stuff too so uh oh this
one this one's good let me i like it let me like some of the
stuff he made there's like he does like lots of like minor
like not minor but huge mods on figures like oh my god i saw
the dragon one and i was like holy Fuck.
The dragon one was was so talented.
Like videos.
Uh, watch this.
Look at
that.
Oh my god, he carved all that out of a fucking styrofoam.
Like he carved skills!
He actually carved skills out of a fucking styrofoam.
Yeah, he's making the dragon.
Dragon.
What the fuck the head?
Get this guy a 3D printer.
Like, this is cyrofoam!
This is better than 3D printer.
Bro, this is hat made.
He don't need... Yeah, he is the printer, guys.
This man is the fucking 3D printer.
3D printer.
This goes so hard.
Like, I recently discovered his Channa.
Like, he...
Not only can he make...
Not only can he make, like, whole, like, props for his
figures, but he can make a fucking figure himself.
He doesn't even need to buy figures anymore.
He can literally make them.
What's the channel name?
It's, uh, Yoshi Channa.
Got a 3D printer.
Do you have any kind of stories to see if he can take it
again?
Yes, Toriyama!
I love the editing too.
I feel like those like The the creative side of youtubers
can edit so well
Okay, not the deep fake again All right, I'm sure you guys
normal videos now chat i'm showing you guys normal videos
now all right i'm trying to find all right let's see oh this
one's what this one i saw it was pretty funny i wish gender
reveals were as fun as this
how is this normal this should be the norm for gender
reveals Dude, I...
I'm tired of all of...
Oh my god, he did like The Undertaker.
Joki, please define normal.
This should be normal.
I'm tired of all the force fires that are being started
because of gender reviews.
I'm so tired.
And the cakes, too.
Cakes aren't original.
Much less proper.
damage exactly it's a boy also there is which one was it uh
see what are things can i was i gonna show you guys uh
uh uh i'm trying there's like videos i've liked as well i'm
gonna look through my archives oh my god i love these are
like tours around like cool places in Japan and there's one
where it's like literally a town dedicated to dinosaurs so
like I was watching this and it's like a whole train that's
just donos it's like a dinosaur train I thought it was so
cool I was like this is so cute I don't want to be on this
train name please it's called it's got japan japan's largest
dinosaur museum it's so it's so interesting it's like it's
like those like trains that are themed so like there's like
pokemon theme trained and like uh and like others but this
one's donald theme look oh my god there's a t-rex head i was
watching this video like a couple of weeks ago it's so cool
So you ride this train to go to the museum.
It's so cute.
There's like so many interesting ones.
And there's like...
Oh, this one.
This one's scary.
I'll be on this train.
Clever, gruh.
He watched the pretty random videos.
I just...
I don't know.
I'm very...
cultured I guess I watch a lot of fucking random videos I
grew up on the internet finally a normal video my algorithm
is like crazy I just watch like different stuff I'm not I
don't like just watch funny videos I watch like craft videos
and stuff and insight into doki's mind look at that it's so
cute i want to sit next to this and then there's like a
museum it's just a museum dedicated to it and stuff so
there's like dino themed food and everything and what's this
oh my god merch buy my merch anyway so i thought this
channel was really interesting because I enjoy because they
tour around Japan showing like interesting like themed
places and stuff and then oh my god okay this is one of my
favorite craft videos
I don't know you know this they make like clay woozoo clay I
really enjoy their stuff it's so cute and very peaceful they
mostly do like Minecraft because of the algorithm
But I found the way they do, like, the clay art to be, like,
really creative.
Like, I like the little, like, the template they use to help
make the clay art.
Minecraft IRL.
Yeah, that's what he does.
So interesting.
And he put his pieces together.
It's so peaceful.
But you can see that it slowly becomes...
Like, look at that!
Oh my god, it's all coming together.
It's very satisfying.
What a submarine!
It's a fucking Minecraft shipwreck.
And they're making the...
They're making the bottom base of it, I think.
Yeah, so they're making the...
and the sand biome.
So, so nice.
Very relaxing.
I can do that.
Yeah?
Where's your 2 million subscribers channel?
Where is it?
Oh my god, it fits perfectly.
I like how there's like Christmas background music in the
background where's yours exactly that is why I'm not
talented enough and I said I joined people's content for
react
that's why I don't have two million subscribers let's go
react at these
Wait, what's that?
What is...
Oh, that's not the seaweed, right?
I haven't watched this video yet.
I watched his other clay videos.
Oh my god.
Imagine, like, putting...
Those could be, like, surgeon fingers, too.
I feel like instead of becoming a surgeon, a lot of...
It's either you be a surgeon with those, like, steady hands
or, like, uh, or a crafter.
Yeah, the tiny details.
And then the coral.
Oh, my God.
They're all broken.
This could, but this is cooler.
Look at that.
That's so fucking tiny.
Oh, I love Tiny Kitchen.
I watch their stuff, too.
I love Tiny Kitchen.
Grab it.
Thank you for the tier one stuff.
Thank you.
tiny sea pickles and then the coral and the seaweed and then
the tiny bow oh god with a chest that's so cute it's so tiny
oh my god there's jack black
toky please true jack black's gonna be steve in minecraft
you guys didn't know that it's so cute finally jack black is
real oh the tiny axolotl yeah
i'm serious he's gonna be he's gonna be steve in minecraft
they just finished filming oh my god the axolotl is so cute
oh i love his stuff and
then you're gonna add resin i love the crafting channels
they're so relaxing to watch
i thought she was joking holy shit it's so tiny next to the
lego i didn't realize how tiny it was
and then you're gonna put resin on it
wait they're making their own dye around
My god.
They didn't even buy a diorama.
They made their own diorama.
Oh god.
Pushing that down would like make me so scared.
Yeah, they made their little wood stand.
I'd be so scared pushing that down.
And so they have to mix the resin.
thing about resin is that you have to it has to be like 50
50 exactly you have because of chemistry if it's not 50 50
exactly you you fuck up the resin
so good and the air bubbles make sense because it's water
holy shit
are you gonna take out take off the uh are you gonna take
out the glass part to like keep that in it's so sick i know
he's so talented i love his stuff yeah you fuck up the resin
it's done for you have to remake the whole thing i know it's
so good i love his i love his works it's actually so good
everything is like super precise and everything all right
now that we're talking about crafting channel let me show
you guys another uh another craft person that i like to
watch uh let me see if i could find it let's see where is it
i love watching craft channels it's like my life it's uzu
clay oh there i love like these like pokemon cards dioramas
too these i think these are really unique like the 3d card
dioramas that stuff is that's like that's so pretty those
are really cool yeah
and because they need like multiple too they need more than
one card to make this so they have to like like they want to
use like authentic pokemon cards so like they have to make
buy like multiple copies of it
i love doll life was one of my favorite uh doll creators um
and also speaking of dolls because I saw a lot of people,
like, the Doki Bird doll dropped from Moonlight Jewel as
well.
I love watching doll videos.
But, like, the Doki Bird doll video dropped as well.
I haven't watched it yet.
Like, oh, look.
Holy shit, it's so pretty.
I want, I want, like, a Doki Bird card diorama one day in
the future.
That's so pretty.
it's so good all right before we do we should like watch
something fucked up before we watch something uh normal
man i wish i could show like some of the animation channels
i watch but the humor in it might is like really up because
i told you guys like so my favorite animation channel is
like there's cast there's flash gets uh and there's meat
canyon but like i feel like if i show you guys
the humor's not for everybody but like those are that's my
humor that's technically my humor um let's see oh i saw like
this song for learning japanese and i thought it was like um
really cute
look this is by
let's learn japanese today
but those who need to learn japanese this is not actually
helpful
okay the reason why is that like i saw this of it which was
really nice.
.
This is how this is how do I learn Japanese.
That's that's that's cute that you think that I'm ever gonna
learn Japanese My brain my my my brain cannot fit another
language Thank you for the twitch prime.
Thank you think not with that attitude We've tried we've
tried so much many times guys that's cute that you guys
think i'm ever gonna learn that's so true um let's see what
else what else i want to show you guys uh all right let's
look at the oh my god okay have you guys seen those like rug
videos i've been like watching okay i've been watching like
the people make rug okay a lot of the videos I watch is
actually just like relaxing videos too like some of my
favorite channels but I love watching people make rugs I
don't know why I just think it's like super soothing it's so
interesting too the rug making videos no not the cleaning
ones I'm just watch people make rugs like that's it that's
it I literally watch people make rugs
oh it's so nice too the asmr of it it sounds so relaxing
it's so talented too because you have to be like super
precise with everything and look at that and then trimming
it all and then making it so that like things are making it
so that these are more like bumpy than the others oh i've
seen the art restoration video Yeah, I have.
Look at that.
Oh my god, I want this rug.
Can someone make a dokeybird rug?
All right, let's watch the doll video.
I haven't watched it yet.
I saved it, though.
Here it is.
Hey-ho.
So if you guys been watching me for a while, you probably
know that I have made some VTuber dolls in the past.
As me, I'm a VTuber.
I love making videos.
I thought how about I make another VTuber doll before I am
taking a tiny break from posting because She's talking about
me guys a lot amazingly enough the decision who to make was
made pretty easy when I saw that the amazing Duckybird
hosted a cherry stream and that's me Duckybird to
participate in that the artworks and items that the artist
offered would then be auctioned off and The proceeds would
go to cherry so I applied get accepted and offered a slot of
a custom Duckybird doll that will go which is what we are
going to do today as always blue pixie did an amazing job by
already sculpting a beautiful face and some of those are my
eyes so how about we get my 3d printer and some resin
prepped and start this project by printing the doll holy
shit what the fuck is that what is that machine is that 3d
printer wait what are 3d printers like that now oh my god
that has to be a fucking oh it's a resin printer they can 3d
print resin now wait that's insane that has to be crazy
expensive oh my god those are my legs whoa naked i really
love the little smug smile on her face and i'm happy that
the printing and assembling went so well and now that the
preparations are done we can now Lude tomato hashtag as a
full-time content creator.
I have to make sure to stay always on top of the game When
it comes to trends on social media one recent trend that I
picked up was people telling their own stories through short
form.
Yeah, bro Those is I wanted to learn more about this subject
and then found.
Oh my god.
Okay from Holly as a never okay Sorry, I'm gonna skip your
ad
her she reminded me of this other channel that i really like
to watch i think it's nerdy is what is it that she it's also
like a crafting channel too uh her like personality reminds
me of that channel where it's i'm trying to remember they
like make like really cool fat like really cool gaming stuff
as well they once made like a custom was it a pc that was
like inspired by cyberpunk i'm trying to remember the name
we should watch some of their stuff nerd forge yes I love
NerdForge!
This time I start by gluing the bangs on my favorite
channels.
An essential item that I found recently for making wigs is
this matte styling wax.
Because with this you can really mold the hair into shape.
It's amazing.
To make Docky's bangs a little more spiky, I thin out the
hair by vertically cutting into them and then use the
styling wax and heat to mold them in shape.
The curling wand is an excellent tool for flattening down
the hair as well.
When I was satisfied with the look, I then proceed and glue,
cut and style her hemobangs.
The front of her hairstyle was actually not that easy to
mimic, which is why I decided to start the wig with it this
time.
The hemobanks are kind of like layered and it was a bit
tricky to make that work.
Once I was satisfied with the look on the front, I glued
more layers on her middle part on top of the head.
And then decided to use my thinning shears to thin out the
hair.
I thought my skin, the skin suit was easier.
And then finally start on the back of the head.
For the pigtail look, I will go around here in the direction
of the pigtails on the back of her head.
and believe me it was but I basically just had to pull all
the glued hair into a pigtail and then for the final layers
I prepped a bunch of folded around glued wifts which I now
will be using to create all the parting lines on the wig
this was a lot of work and I've been working on the wig for
the whole day already and it was evening and I was pretty
tired so I did that off-camp and I'm sorry oh my god look at
all that hair to make so many layers I cut this shape from
fabric Thank you, thank you!
Yeah!
Hello, everybody.
It's me, Ducky Bird.
She's on YouTube.
But today I'm on Twitch because I'm a React Andy today.
I made a spade charm to it that I made with my laser cutter.
I also made another ribbon the same way in white.
Oh my gosh, the ribbon's so cute.
And here you can see the final wig so far, on which I now
can finally attach the ribbons with some hot glue.
I actually did try to make Ducky's head out of fabric, but I
failed miserably.
So blue came to the rescue here and sculpted Ducky's head so
I could then see he printed in resin.
And I then just have to simply paint it according to Ducky's
very hard to make.
I love how flawless it looks and will now also glue it to
the wig so that it won't fall off and potentially break in
worst case since resin is a little bit more brittle than
filament and tends to break more easily.
The finished wig looks so cute already and I'm really proud
of the little bows.
I'm not a fan of making the layers.
the end.
Let's paint Docky's face next.
The pixie did such a nice job sculpting it that you can
already tell by the sculpt itself that it is really
Dockybird.
As always I'm giving the face some sheen with pearly
shimmers.
You can really go a bit overboard with them as sealing them
with Mr. Super Clear later on will make them disappear a
little again.
I also add a little bit of blushing to different areas of
the face.
I know enemy faces tend to look more flat so adding a bit
more blushing i think that's like for example the hardest
part with uh when i was satisfied with the hardest part with
like painting figures is to make it not like one dimensional
type deal and adding shading i mean that's like the hardest
part i've seen so many like custom figures and stuff that
like um that like forget to do like the important parts of
shading because it's so hard to make it look right as well i
then can finally go in with black acrylic paint and line the
lashes with it.
Of course, I also have to line Docky's cute little smug
smile using some gouache paint.
Mistakes can be carefully scratched away with an exacto
knife.
So cute.
To give the eyebrows a little bit more of a blonde look, I
decided to use a little bit of pastel yellow on the middle
of them, and I really like the look.
For the finishing touches of the face, I'm using my favorite
iridescent sparkly shimmers on her cheeks and forehead
before sealing her off the final time.
To make Docky's eyes, I made these tiny templates on my iPad
and and printed them onto some cardboard paper.
I'm then taking my half sphere mold and will use the third
biggest one.
Using some UV resin, I drop one drop of it into the mold and
then place the iris onto the resin upside down like this.
I let it cure for a minute and then add some white UV resin
that I mixed with some white resin pigment.
I cure it again for about three minutes and then it's time
to demold the eye.
And it's for me.
Oh my God.
This happened because my mold might be a little old at this
point and this white.
But don't worry, we're here to rescue it because I can
simply use some UV top coat and gloss it over.
And to make the resin spread evenly, I can use a lighter and
then cure it in my V-Lamp.
She's blind.
The finished eyes look like this and I think they're really
pretty and super shy.
I mean, honestly, like, that's not a surprise.
I'm just so cute.
Oh my God.
The face already looks so much like a docky.
So I absolutely cannot wait to make her outfit next.
Docky's outfit.
I actually really had to think how to even be able to
realize it.
In the end I opted to make an underdress with the white top
part and a layered skirt and then basically make a black
dress topper separately.
And of course then make the jacket, accessories and shoes.
So how about we start with the underdress first.
First let's make the skirt of Docky's dress.
Since it has three layers and little white strips on them I
decided to cut the strips from white fabric vinyl.
vinyl has such a nice and neat finish that i really enjoy
using it after cutting i just have to weed it out and here
you can see i cut three ruffled pieces from blue fabric
already and will iron on those vinyl strips onto them first
i'm just like thinking how expensive all of the machinery
for to make these custom dolls like this especially like
resin dolls too the bottom seams and bottom top seams of the
smaller strips by yeah she's so good at like arts and crafts
gathering threads and now have you guys seen this like
fashion designer that does like pop culture out like does
like outfits inspired by like movies and tv shows and like
cartoons and then she did one from like the rogers rabbit
the the unrealistic expectations of women outfit uh what's
her name that what's her name she did like uh from roger
rabbit uh jessica yeah jessica rabbit have you guys seen
that the there's like this like youtuber she does like very
little uh she does like she doesn't upload a lot of videos
um but she she has like almost a million subscribers from
the very few videos that she has uploaded it because it's
just so good i'll show it to you guys later however this
whole skirt I saw the short of it and then I watched the
video.
Wow!
So I basically had to go back to the drawing board and try
to figure out how to make this skirt look better.
I ended up going with a pleated look instead.
So I prepped some new strips for the skirt and cleaned them
up.
Then I sewed the two bottom pleated parts to a tool strip
and then attached the top pleated part to that tool strip.
And then I pressed the pleats according to the markings on
the top pleated part.
For the top part of Ducky's dress, I cut this white fabric
piece and then attach it.
actually like so talented.
I sew it, press it and then stitch it down like this so I
can now pull in a little rubber thread through the tunnel
that we just created.
If you have trouble threading in threads like this through
needles, a lot of TH, you can just use some tape, attach it
to the end of the thread, cut it into a tip and then thread
it through the needle like this.
This is just such a good trick I learned recently that I had
to share it with you guys.
And then I just proceed and thread the rubber band into the
top.
When that was done successfully, I then add a the bottom
part of the top piece and gather it to the length of the
blue lower part of the top i pin it together and sew it
finished sides in afterwards it looks like this and as you
can see i already pinned oh that's the top part of my outfit
sorry the popcorn's hiding it show them on good sides in and
boom a cute cat appeared a very important assistant i might
say here you can see the finished skirt and now i can take
the finished part of the dress oh wait it's turning the
skirt before sewing the skirt and top together finished
sides in my cat the ruffle straight up so pretty she was
however very interested in the glue cap the sewn together
dress looks like this and i now just have to pin together
the back seam and sew it together about 2.5 inches leaving
just enough of a gap for the closure the finished dress
turned out so good and you can see that even though i have
been making dolls for years sometimes i have to remake
things in order to make them look better and more accurate
and that's okay we learn from amazing sometimes let's make
the black topper that docky wears on top of her dress next i
prepped the fabric pieces with white vinyl strips already
and i'll now bring the cat back where is my kitty cam i will
now attach the blue lining pieces on which i also iron on
some white vinyl strips next i place them onto the black
parts good sides in and hem them on when flapping around the
lining parts it really looks like watch like this in the end
i already cut and prep the skirt for the top by cleaning up
the bottom i think like honestly like the hardest part with
clothes is based making clothes based off of like anime
characters is that a lot of the clothes that that like
people design for anime characters looks like this is very
hard to make reality because they're not like physically
possible so it's like always super impressive that they're
able to replicate in real life gluing some tiny golden half
it's like designers like manga manga artists and like anime
artists dude the design is to make like clothes that look
cool not like actually real with these final steps the dress
tupper is done and i'm super happy how it turned out it
looks so much like ducky's outfit i think especially the
little details like the blue lining part with the white
stripes really make it look very accurate to the yeah art
cares not for gravity i first take the sleeves from gray
cotton fabric and prepped them by pulling and gathering
threads on the top and bottom seams.
I then gather the lower part of them and take these tiny
little cuffs that I prepped by ironing them in half and now
pin them to the gathered sleeve parts and sew them on.
When done with that the sleeves look really cute already and
I can now also gather the top part of them.
I then set them aside for a bit and first we'll sew on the
facing for the raglan collar to the bodice of the jacket.
Of course, I fray-checked all my fabric pieces to make sure
they won't trade before.
And after sewing on and steaming the face, Kingdom Hearts
cosplay are very impressive, especially the shoes.
The Kingdom Hearts shoes.
They are not practical at all.
And now I can finally take the crept sleeves and sew them
onto the bodice of the jacket with magic.
Last but not least, I take my cat and gently push her out of
the way so I can show you that I just needed to close the
sleeve and side stitch of the jacket still.
I pin them together neatly and try to match up all the live
action movie that disney approved i heard that was like the
hardest part i pinned it before and now okay sorry this is
off topic because someone mentioned kingdom hearts you know
how like the smash brothers trailer for for sora has no
donald and goofy because getting sora on his own was really
hard getting getting disney characters in smash brothers
like okay this is the perfect cut by the way the perfect
angle for you guys uh but if you don't if you notice um if
you notice in the kingdom hearts smash brothers reveal
trailer the the the there there's no donald or goofy um at
all there's no reference to donald or goofy and even then
getting the mickey mouse keychain on the keyblade was in
itself incredibly difficult to do because like you know
disney was like i don't know i'll definitely attach it to
the jacket with my beloved The horizontal strip is the final
touch and will attach to the opposite side of the jacket
with a little velcro on the inside.
That's why like Donald and Goofy doesn't exist in Smash
Brothers.
Or like there's no reference to Donald or Goofy in the for
Sora in Smash Bros.
It's really difficult, but it's a challenge that I really
enjoy conquering.
Feels like mini cosplay somehow.
Did I actually ever tell you that I used to cosplay back in
the day pre-moonlight jewel times?
Let's make Docky's boots next.
I cut the boot pieces from blue fabric.
already and first sew together the front seam but just about
half an inch after sewing and ironing it it looks like this
and i can now proceed to glue around the seam allowance of
the upper boot part i then take this strip i cut from white
fabric and disney will fuck up the kingdom oh absolutely
disney is past prime unless it goes into another renaissance
era it looks really this is all about like corporate uh
money greed slash greed now for that i care also disney you
want to sponsor of the boot and instead of a zipper totally
not because i completely forgot to order some i will attach
an elastic fabric on the back of the boot this time i first
glue around the top seam of the elastic fabric and then pin
it to the boot piece like this by my silence along the boot
part of the boot and glue the rest with contact adhesive
afterwards it looks really neat corporate green now not yet
and after that was done i turned the boot inside out and
finally seem good sets in I turn it inside well you see me
sponsored by Disney you would know an old cereal packaging
and will now glue the bottom of the boot oh my god how is
that not sensing for the shoe bases I printed these guide
boys I also prepped these tiny buffers I cut from PVC
covered in silver vinyl on my laser cutter and now take tiny
pleather strips and thread them through the buckles first As
you can see, I attached one set of buckle straps to the boot
already and will now do the same to the other.
I simply attached them with glue and afterwards can finally
glue the upper boot part to the shoe base using some woohoo
or purpose glue.
Last but not least, I just attached a tiny golden star to
the boot as well.
How tiny this is, the little stars.
I decided to make them from fabric rather than pleather
because you can see that on Ducky's original artwork, the
boots do actually have some wrinkles and I think the fabric
choice resembles this perfectly here.
All right, the main part of the outfit is done.
Let's make all of Docky's accessories.
For her stocking, I will be using an actual human kite with
stripes like this and cut out the stocking pattern from it.
I then clean up the other seam with glue.
That's so resourceful.
Not wasting materials.
Afterwards, it looks like this.
Because you can like, you know, there's like, if you want to
make more stock, you just get the same material.
And then take this tiny white lace and glue it to the upper
part of the choker.
I will do the exact same to the bottom part of the choker as
well and end up with something like this.
Now I carefully glue a tiny satin ribbon to the front of the
choker and also add this tiny prepped folded ribbon to the
middle of the choker as well.
Oh well, I at least try to.
For the final step, I take this tiny golden star and attach
it to the middle of the just attached satin ribbon.
And with a tiny velcro on the back added, the choker is also
done.
I didn't even know my boots were made of fabric, guys.
aesthetic instead of practicality that's what i mean i
didn't even know i learned something new today i was like
whoa my boots are fabric to really bond the two components i
use a little metal roll it's a really nice tool for that i
proceed and cut the tiny back pieces from the material and
now first attach some glue to the back inside of the back to
be able to attach the little side strip to it afterwards i
attach the front piece in the same fashion and end up with
this It's the back for all my seething tools.
I don't know you guys know this.
I'm a thief, by the way I don't know if you guys forgot or
not I glued it to the top part already and now we'll attach
the bottom magnet as well with some super glue When it was
dry the back opens and closes nicely Yeah, it's like where I
put all the tools to do the thieving things, you know like
the thief tools yeah turkey what's in what tools to be able
to be used you know i glue them both to one side of the back
post and then carefully glue them around the leg on one of
my novas you know those tools correct last but not least i
added these teeny tiny decorations to the back as well with
some glue and tweezers and finish off the little leg back
like that as well only one more accessory to make the gloves
for these i simply take a folded and cleaned up rectangle
cut from jersey fabric and will sew them along the short
seam just leaving open a tiny gap for ducky's thumb kind of
the same way i made iron mouse's gloves back in the day i
can then simply put them into the hands like this and i
really love this easy but nice technique i feel he's so
stupid you need fingerprints all the accessories for ducky
bird's doll are finally done making accessories is
definitely my favorite thing to do i was 50 done with those
gloves i've been loving ever since i was a kid i'm
especially proud of that little leg back The doll is
actually done at this point, but for those of you who know
me, you probably know that there is this.
Best thief ever.
Exactly, the doll stand.
I have conveniently vectorized the logo already, so how
about we make that stand now with a final little montage.
Oh, wow.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Oh, it's so pretty!
That's like my logo!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's the stand?
Oh, I love it!
Like the laser cut of the acrylic.
And with that, the doll stand is also done and I can finally
assemble the doll completely for the very first time.
And I was absolutely blown away by how cute she turned out
to be!
It's me!
Ducky!
Ducky bird!
She called me cute!
I just put her together and she is everything.
But I know you're probably dying to see her.
So presentation time!
Yay!
Ducky bird's real!
Oh!
Bro, you can barely tell which one's the real Ducky bird.
Which one is it, guys?
Can you tell?
Who will you shoot?
The hair is so long!
Oh my god!
Shoot the bright one!
Who's talking?
You'll never know!
That's so cute!
I love how it came out.
Oh my god, I love like the hair the hair is like so well
done of all the layers and everything That actually so cute
And here's my finished ducky doll and I hope you love her as
much as I do I also hope her new owner will be super happy
with this doll as well The new owner me I will be going on a
tiny little break because I'm actually getting married Oh
wait, sorry, I did not mean to fast forward that part where
you get married isn't it we're just going to be happy
congratulations to the wedding oh my god uh yeah but i'm
getting one of the dolls and also like the person who won
the auction is getting the other doll that's so cute though
oh my gosh huge shout out again to moonlight jewel i love
their work i remember watching their work before or um in
the past so i was so surprised when she like contacted us
saying that she wants to make a doll of me for the charity
and like a huge shout out for them.
It was like really nice to them to well they I paid them by
the way so it's not like she did it for free because I feel
like obviously all the artists need to be supported and I
was so happy that she offered to offered her services for
the charity auction and I'm so happy to receive one of the
dolls I get to receive a dokeybird doll.
All right, guys, let me show you guys.
Okay, the Jessica Rabbit outfit.
Okay, Jessica Rabbit fashion.
I was like, oh my God.
I think this one, making a Jessica Rabbit.
Okay, this, oh my God, yeah, she has like 148 million views
on this.
I feel like you guys must have seen this.
It's actually insane how talented her, how talented she is
in fashion.
Here.
Picking an hourglass body
Like what the fuck
You can do that
Like oh my god
Like what She went from an A to a D
My ribs hurt.
No, the thing is, she didn't even do it so much.
And like, D for death.
Like, look.
All she did was just pad it up.
It was just illusion.
She got some foam and padded the fuck out of her thighs.
And she got, like, four fucking bras.
life is a lie it's all pads i love her stuff she doesn't
even have that many videos but she her like look at how many
videos she has in general um but she already has three
almost three million views because of like how talented she
is as a fashion designer like oh my god
You're going for like an extreme look.
Like look!
Hello,
my name is Shay and I like to make things.
And this week I am telling you how I made my Jessica Rabbit
costume.
Okay.
Before I can even throw for it, I'm vaguely following these
two tutorials.
But I'm just gonna kind of wing it.
We'll see.
I should do this.
Okay, wrapping yourself in saran wrap.
little like chicken leg hip shapes and cutting it all apart
to get your pattern it cut a hole in my shirt this could be
you guys jaguns raise them onto four inch upholstery foam
you can add this for your butt you guys wouldn't like have
more ass add like these pads behind your butt i think once i
shave them down it's actually gonna be really thick i could
be thick you guys can be thick too just gonna kind of go for
it and cut off all the edges until it looks very nice okay
no more squats guys look holy look at that no more squats
but I think this is far too extreme even for Jessica Rabbit
so the hips looked good but they were way too big for my
body shape so I'm doing take two this time with two inch
foam last time I used four hips so this is what it looks
like with the corset I think it's a good shape I think it's
still very without being as crazy
okay second one is definitely more natural second one is
definitely a lot more natural version one is it just me
version one is Dexter's mom this is literally Dexter's mom
right there
This is a Jessica Rabbit shoe.
Now all that's left to do is make the booze.
The stuffing bras and stuffing them with socks is an A cup.
It may be a B cup, but I have very little chest to work with
in general.
So for building my chest, I really am trying to like push
one another up and then build the rest out with padding.
First up is just normal push-up bra that fits my size.
This is from Victoria's Secret.
As you can see, it's not a lot, but it's a little more.
To make it a little bit more, And then she adds a second.
Oh, wait, she puts pads in there?
Starting to get a little more.
It was time for bra number two.
And then bra number two.
How much does it send to it?
Oh my God.
Is this how they do that?
Holy shit.
What do we want?
Science.
Damn.
It's pretty big.
That's all I got.
Let's put on the hips.
Magic.
Living a fantasy Again, that is all foam and then all foam
the power of theirs Chat is this real?
Why don't you find out yourself by four bras It go even
beyond the super shade She's like 40% foam Holy shit
Alright, sponsored break.
Okay, I need to like what the fuck?
Okay, I also added boning to this lining layer The foam
stays on And with this chest Not gonna lie this is a lot
more boobage than I thought I would be right guys This is so
crazy Bro, this is actually crazy It's okay if it looks like
it's falling out because that's kind of how her boobs are
She went too far I kind of love it.
I kind of love it.
But now that we got the body, now that we got the dress, she
kind of loves it, guys.
Okay, and yeah, like...
So this is the sequence.
What the hell?
Look at this.
What the fuck?
This is the same person.
The world is...
That's actually crazy.
She's so talented.
That's a friend.
entrap is this real she looks amazing oh my god this is the
channel by the way she deserves it i'm not subscribed
because now i am it's because she says she rarely uploads
this is the reason why like whenever she does upload like it
just pops up in my recommended whenever she does upload
Because it's so rare.
Alright, wait wait, wait.
Doll rifle.
Not Doll rifle.
I love Nerd Forge.
I love Nerd Forge stuff.
Nerd Forge stuff is like...
I love her builds.
Um...
But like.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys the...
What was it?
Which one is my favorite one?
I think my favorite one has to be like her PC builds.
When she turns...
Oh yeah, she turns her PC.
PS5 into a Dwarven Kingdom.
Look at this.
I'm Martina, and I have issues.
I've been waiting for my PS5 to arrive, which it did after
months.
But now, all I can think about is how normal it looks.
And I've been wanting to do things to it.
But I keep telling myself, Martina, there's no need.
I mean, it looks perfectly fine.
Here, let's do that.
Okay, so, like, all she, she, like, obviously, foam is your
best friend.
But it's actually crazy that she turned it into some
fucking...
Dwarven Kingdom.
I love NerdForge.
I love the stuff she uploads.
I'm not subscribed.
Let me subscribe.
I was subscribed, okay?
Just not on this channel.
Now I'm subscribed on this channel.
I know it looks like I've done a lot here, but really all
I've done is just cut some stairs.
Balsa, think of a tier one sub.
Thank you.
Way and over, he was foam.
It's not that bad big holes.
I'm gonna create some spacers in here and then try to cover
up some of the cracks Nerd forage
Nerd forage But that It's so cool And now let's fill all of
these little gaps here with some sculpt them all It makes so
many things with like fucking foam Like I mean like cosplay
for armor it was originally done by like NerdForge oh my god
there's this channel i really like um that does like that
looks they do like dnd uh skits i find it really funny i'm
trying to remember the name does anybody remember does
anyone like remember the channel name that does like um dnd
re uh dnd skits i remember the name right now borders that i
can place around let's get some beams some details you stuff
them on there all that work for a console that has no games
there's a lot yeah viva viva the dirt league yes that one
yes that's one my favorite channels too i love their skits
they're so funny he's going so fast he's shaking for william
working so hard all right let me skip a little bit because
i've seen this before if you guys want to watch more check
out their channel god the painting too all mixed up now
hopefully it's like wait okay start at the top here i need
to show you guys the finished product this is like the
electronics and stuff guys skip skip skip it's because i
watched this already if you want to watch like the full
actual videos check them out give them a subscribe give them
a view give nerd fortune view they deserve it holy would it
not overheat just don't play cyberpunk it's that easy but we
didn't watch it sad
support the original video nerds exactly not true reaction
chat how dare you dokey not leech off their entire video
where's my real react andy
Pikes, thank you for that raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, everybody.
My name is TokiBade.
I usually stream on the YouTube, but today I'm apparently a
failed React Andy.
I'm a fake.
Holy shit.
I love, like, Archie's so good at, like, crafting and
painting and art and everything.
She's so talented.
They have fake reactors.
How dare you not watch the entire video and steal all their
content, Doki.
What's the point?
Are people this talented?
It's because they're...
It's because they actually...
They actually, like, get up from their PC.
let's try to turn this on and see what it looks like for the
first time and hopefully everything just works please does
it not work like the Xbox like you can turn it on does it
not work like the X no she's almost perfect she makes
feelings stop okay huh thank you for gifting a tier one sub
for both cookie and cat thank you thank you the LAVs looks
so good
fake gamer shake my head
long set that is so good I want to close up give me the
close up give me the close up oh my god look at that holy
shit and that means it is time it looks so sick it's like on
your fucking desk like holy shit it could overheat just
don't play cyberpunk just play fucking pepper pig on this
looks so good though
that's a fucking ps5 guys
it's oozing lava it's gonna overheat
i love her stuff she's like actually one of my favorite
crafting channels too honors okay yeah wait uh i'm not gonna
watch yourself but what was it uh viva the dirt league um i
mean i have six million subscribers but uh check out if you
like dungeons and dragons i highly suggest checking out this
channel because they do a lot of really funny yes you can
tell that i watch every every one of their dnd stuff i i
don't care about the i don't care about these the stuff i
just watched the dungeons and dragons ones but i suggest
checking out their channel as well uh i really like their
stuff anyway subscribe look they always pop up in my
recommended that's why i forget to subscribe i always forget
to subscribe because they always whenever they upload new
videos it just pops up in my recommended chat
I swear They just deliver it to me exactly They like deliver
Deliver the content to me So I always forget to subscribe
Because it's just there It's just there By the way Hit that
subscribe button on YouTube guys I'm not just there guys I'm
not please subscribe to me as well You see that's how you
subscribe to a person You know So you can also Subscribe to
someone like me on YouTube as well I'm trying like there was
another channel I really want to show you guys, but I'm
trying to remember Remember the name of it.
Fuck.
It was also a crafter channel like similar to Nourge Forge.
Um I'm trying to remember it.
It's like similar to Nourge Forge as well.
Oh, I can't remember I can't remember the channel.
Let me look at my let me look at how how my recommended is
like now
Let me see how fucked my recommended is like at the moment.
Oh, it's not as bad.
It's not that bad, actually.
Thank God.
It's not that bad, chat.
Let's see.
I mean, there's like other channels that I really like to
watch.
Oh, this one!
Wait, is this the same one that made the...
They made the Pokemon...
No, not this one.
There was, like, a channel that does, like, Pokemon crafts.
That really, like...
Let's see.
Pokemon crafts.
I want to see if I could find it.
Oh!
Is this one?
This is north of the...
Oh, north of the border is really nice.
I love north of the border.
Oh my god.
North of the border is more like...
Really fucked up dioramas.
So...
I'm scared of scrolling down.
Because I saw what it was down.
But like it's for like more like...
More like gritty dioramas.
Because...
If I scroll...
Whoa!
But I also enjoy their content as well.
What is that?
Yeah.
Oh, yes, I remember!
It's the one with the Halloween ones.
Halloween decoration DIY.
I think I...
Was it that channel?
I'm trying to remember the channel's name.
Was it Wicked Makers?
Oh, I love this channel!
This channel is really good.
This one.
They like actually made like, um, they take like Halloween
decorations and then like make them, oh my god, this looks
so good.
They remake them into like more like horror themed stuff,
which is really cool.
They take like super cheap Halloween decorations and like
DIY it.
Like look at this.
Look at the.
In this video, we're going to build a real catnap
animatronic that actually breathes fog.
Or Jamie and Jane, we bring your favorite monsters to life.
Like Yeah, thank you for the three subscribe tier three for
four months.
Thank you.
Yeah, those are real It's not even like 3d Which is not easy
Catnap is the main boss in poppy playtime chapter three and
it's well just look just look at it also You know like wait
let me show you guys So we're gonna zoom it if you guys want
to actually check out the full video.
Let me subscribe I swear they are my favorite channels guys
I swear to god they're my favorite channel i used to be
subscribed i used to be subscribed on a different
channel i swear i hope they make this themselves they've
done it they've done oh wait they can make they're starting
to make their own animatronics holy fuck that's actually
crazy they used to like just repurpose old animatronics for
this but like but I want to show you guys what's like wait
I'm trying to like show should we try it on holy shit that
shit's so creepy imagine having that like as a kid
trick-or-treating imagine trick-or-treating as a kid and
seeing this
well the box works but the whole thing started to collapse
we fixed it we had to spread the legs out more and they need
to be just want some candy angle because the pose is so
dynamic doesn't balance otherwise but it works and look we
can even push on it you know what though i hate to say it
that box expensive that's not diy i took off a whole lot of
material and i don't even know if you can tell but there's a
that weird cat's back ma work on this for like three more
days and probably still not be happy with it but at some
point you have to call it and it has to be done because we
have to move on yeah oh my god the wire is coming out of the
eyes okay we're gonna i'm gonna zoom past guys to like its
limits i know you guys really want to watch the diy part but
guys i want to see the finish piece if you want to watch the
full video check it out i'm being a fake
holy shit i love how like they did the sun's effect where
like if you carve the eye deep enough you can make it so
that i will like follow you around toky please five room and
this is what hangs off of his zipper pole we could just
paint it gold like it is in the game but i've always wanted
a reason to gold leaf something and it seems like super
extravagant and ridiculous but only the best for our boy.
I don't even know what gold leafing is.
Well, it's like super thin.
No, you're supposed to eat that.
Oh my gosh, she's wasting precious gold leaf food.
How would the rich eat?
They can't eat food without the gold leaf.
It's true.
In order for rich people to eat, they eat the gold leaf on
top.
The ritual style.
Oh my god, they use like the pool noodles.
That's so smart.
The pool noodles.
Oh, the rib cage.
It took me several hours, but I got all of the bad paint off
of the nails.
And now I got this cool metallic paint.
We're going to paint it.
In some ways, building Catnap has gone really well.
We've learned so much since we started making animatronics
that we were able to combine it all into this insanely
awesome build.
But at the same time, this project has been the hardest
thing we've ever done.
The longest hours, the most setbacks, difficulty.
For only $3,000 a day, you can starve a...
You can save a starving, rich man.
That's how you get better.
To animate Katnab's head, I'm using a huge servo because the
head is really heavy and we need a lot of torque.
A servo is different than a wiper motor because I can tell
it exactly how to move.
To do that, I'm using this free software called Botango
which is used to animate animatronics instead of writing
code i can just animate in a timeline it's super fun anytime
i want i can just make a new animation for catnap and then
when it's ready we export it to the arduino y'all we just
did a test run i can't wait for you to see him in action but
before we do we just want to say oh my god i don't like that
channel and helping us grow this is makes me uncomfortable
just sitting next to it as if like he's friend that's so
creepy
I want one for my six-year-old nephew
Oh god when it's like nighttime too It's so cool though
They've done like they've actually repurposed like uh
They've actually done like repurposing um Like Halloween
decorations too Wait, let me show you guys.
Like the spider one.
Like, they made that.
And I'm going to skip to the end.
We've made a 12-foot spider.
We've made a Minecraft spider.
Like, they've repurposed that and turned it into this, which
is insane.
It's actually crazy.
They repurposed, like, old Halloween decorations to make,
like, actual cool shit.
But I want to watch.
Then watch the channel!
Wicked Maker!
I'm just showing you an example!
I've seen this video already!
There's no reaction because I've seen it!
Toki keeps skipping to the end.
Like, look at that.
That's so cool.
I'm showing my favorite...
Guys, it's not you show me...
favorite it's me showing you my favorite channels on
reactive streamer you take that back it's like i'm showing
you my mixtape but instead i'm showing you my favorite
videos there's actually one where they made like last of us
props too um i'll show you the short because i can let's
turn the spirit halloween oh my gosh okay the last of us one
was really creepy uh i remember watching their last of us
one uh light videos here.
Let's turn this spirit Halloween animatronic into a clicker
from the last of us.
A giant mushroom bloom has burst out of the clicker's skull
so first we're gonna cut a big old hole in his face where we
want the mushroom to bloom out.
To make the mushrooms we'll cut a bunch of flowery looking
shapes out of EVA foam.
We use a heat gun to bend and shape the pieces and then
sculpt on top of them with foam clay to bulk them out and
give them some texture.
Blah!
If you look at the clickers in the show they're really
colorful to contrast with a bleak environment.
To match that look, we airbrushed on some really bright
colors and then gave it a brown wash to make it look more
organic.
While I was painting, Jay tweaked the animatronic to give it
a more scary animation.
It's really cool because the one is the crafter and the
other one's the engineer with the electronics, which is
really cool that they're working together for this.
We'll fill any gaps with foam clay and then add lots of
details.
I show you my mixing, but skip until the end of the song.
I just skip to where the drop is.
Like, holy shit, that's so cool.
Oh, the Wicked Makers from our...
That's so cool.
I just skipped to the drop.
Yeah, they made, like...
They've done, like, a lot of stuff, which is really cool.
That's why I love their channel as well.
Because they do, like, a lot of, like...
They repurpose, like, Halloween stuff into, like, actual
cool Halloween decorations.
I mean, there's, like, stuff...
Okay.
Like, because, like, I don't want to go outside.
So instead of going outside, and like, I don't like roller
coasters and like animatronics, but I love watching like,
um, people filming attractions.
So like, I don't know, if you guys know, like attractions
360.
So like, instead of like actually riding the attractions, I
just watch videos of people.
I just watch videos of like other people like showing what's
in the ride.
So I don't have to go on the ride.
Like...
I live...
That's not sad!
I just don't like...
I don't like animatronics!
IRL!
I like...
Okay, I like how I said I don't like animatronics.
I don't like animatronics, but I love watching people make
animatronics.
Because I find it really interesting.
But I don't like them.
IRL.
Like I think it's like...
I'm always like really scared.
I was like, ooh, what if it touches me?
Like, like it just scares the shit out of me.
So I like watching...
experiencing it through video because i'm not actually there
like usually when i do ride because i'll give you an example
i wrote that harry potter one um from like what is it the oh
my god the fucking dementors ride or whatever and then like
i closed my eyes the entire time during universal like you
know the universal rides i closed my eyes and then i just i
i just i just don't experience it and then like the demented
ride and then and then i remember like one of my friends was
like open your eyes oh my god this is the cool part open
your eyes i was like no and then i just rode the entire ride
just closing my eyes like i didn't even open my eyes so then
i was like i was like oh shit what was in there like you
know it's not like i was super young or anything I think
like I was like like like first year of university or
something it's like first year of university and and the and
it's like and then they're like open your eyes you gotta see
this this shit do I see this part and then I just closed my
eyes throughout the ride so never actually like saw what
anything happened I felt it I felt like I I I felt the ride
like felt the wind and i didn't i don't know i don't know
what it was visually what it was so i just like looked up on
youtube what the ride was like and i was like oh hey thank
god i didn't open my eyes because that shit looks scary i
didn't think fucking guy but i love like watching videos of
like oh did you guys see the new adam okay guys spoiler
alert if you guys the new like universal Jurassic Park ride
I'll never ride on it, but...
It's the one... This one's like in Beijing, right?
The Universal Studios?
I'll never ride on it, but it looks so cool.
The Jurassic Road.
Yeah, it's in Beijing.
It's so cool because it's apparently...
uh...
It's apparently like the the dinosaur chases you too.
I love looking at the also like I like looking at the queue
the the what is it called you know when you're in queue and
they have like all these like decorations in queue there's
like a special name for it what is it called because like
sometimes I always I do like the lightning rat the lightning
ticket so you can skip you can skip the line so you skip the
line you don't get to watch all the the the the decorations
from the queue system so that's what I like to look at too
because I get and also you get to like absorb it instead of
like being rushed in the queue it's so cool the pre-show
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you have the lightning ticket you
tend to skip all the pre-show and then you also have to like
you know you have to walk really fast during the pre-show
because you know you want to get on the line oh my god it's
like we're there guys it's like we're riding on the
attraction right now oh my god yeah you get to absorb the
lore of your video it's like we're there holy shit it's so
immersive guys it's like we're just like we're there hands
in the air guys
We're here right now!
We're in Beijing!
This is sad!
What do you mean?
It's so cool.
When it starts chasing you, it's actually so freaky.
So I think it starts, I would never ride this.
I would never I would never ride this
It looks really cool though like it looks so immersive
Really it seems pretty cool.
Yes, but like what if it touches me?
Like that's like I just like my irrational fear of like what
if it just touches me These
dogs look so cool
Like, look, it starts moving!
Holy shit, that's so fucking scary!
It just starts chasing you!
Holy fuck!
Bro, even the car moves!
Because, like, you think they don't chase you, you know,
like, I don't try, they don't move, but then it moves!
okay then this is just like um i hate the i'm not a huge fan
of the uh the screens i wish like i wish they use less
screens that's the my only issue i hate how like amusement
park rides use a lot of screens now oh my god there's a
t-rex i hate the imex imax segments in like any animatronic
in any like amusement park ride It just doesn't feel right.
I thought they were going to kiss.
Just like Godzilla and King Kong.
I love like the whole debate on why is she running with high
heels.
Oh my god, there's Ted.
Meshit.
I want to go to university.
studios in Beijing.
It looks so cool.
You guys see the new like Zootopia land in the universe.
Not universe.
Disney.
Soon Disney will buy Universal.
He's just leaping chat.
So cool though.
Let's see.
Yeah, there's a new Zootopia.
utopia land in disneyland in shanghai uh i swear like the
animatronics there looks like so much to be fair i think
it's also because like universal and the universal land in
disneyland in like shanghai and beijing are more like are
newer builds so they use like newer animatronics and stuff
and it's like obviously since it's newer built the
technology is more high tech and the disneyland and
universals and americas are like fucking old as hell so it's
like super dated so like all like all the newer amusement
parks have all the cutting edge technology even like the
apparently so like oh doggy mug purchased jay thank you for
the 5000 videos thank you thank you even like okay so you is
it like uh america disneyland has the frozen ride right so
america disneyland has the frozen ride and then uh hong kong
disneyland has like the same frozen ride but the
animatronics are better than uh then like america's
disneyland because it's using the newer animatronics where
it's not using the the the what was it the 2d faces where
like they use like the projected faces in america because
that was the old animatronics the newer animatronics
actually uses like uh molded faces for like the frozen let
me see if i can find it it's actually crazy hong kong
disneyland uh frozen versus america anyone oh there's i want
to know if anyone made like a comparison video oh here you
go here you go this is like he did it here you go you can
tell the difference it's actually crazy well Disney did it
they gave the Elsa animatronic a new face this is actually
new footage Disney released for Frozen Ever After this is
Hong Kong Disney Land animatronic it's definitely a major
upgrade from that projected face like look
this is America this is Hong Kong she came out of Star Trek
this is the animatronic I mean because like Hong Kong
Disneyland released a new frozen land the comparison between
the two no fair it's because America I swear I think like
America Disneyland America Disneyland so Disney World is
like the beta test and then after like beta test is over
they're like alright let's export this
so bad both figures are programmed with the exact same
movements and if you look closely the new animatronic's face
matches the exact animation of the projected facial
expressions and it works even better in my opinion yeah it
does this is perfect
someone helping oh my god um but i feel like disney the
disney lands in the like universal studios outside of
america are a lot better is better, I feel like, because
it's newer.
Technology is, like, newer, too.
Oh, and then, like, when...
Okay, it's so freaky.
Okay, wait, wait.
When, like, because they're using projective faces, and
because they're using projective faces, it breaks down.
Okay, wait.
Elsa animatronic malfunction.
And it's just a black screen, and it's so weird.
It's so scary.
It's actually really scary.
Let me see if I can find it.
it okay let's see let's see i can find it it's actually so
scary
wait wait wait look at this
because the projected face breaks down and sometimes like
the face oh and then the mickey mouse right has uses these
too mickey mouse animatronic malfunction okay malfunction
okay i think it's this one right uh i used to i watched some
of the animatronic malfunction videos welcome to tpm i love
tpm uh okay let's see i can find it let's see i think it
this is this one bear frozen uh nope not this one where is
it no that's not oh my god where is the one with the mickey
mouse breaking down i love i love watching animatronic
malfunctions from tpm top 10 disney animatronic malfunction
is it this one where is it six five nope not this one wait
is it this one no no where is it tpm don't you betray me
right now don't you dare oh it's this one wait i think it's
this one okay let me find it let's see let me see if i can
find it guys this is this one okay pirates figment million
dollar bunny carousel frozen ever after oh it's this one
okay here it is here's this is the frozen one i was talking
about function with anna sent in by seora
the glitching projected face looks exactly like the vertical
lines you'd see on a damaged led tv only a little more
unsettling these face malfunctions you'll get something more
on the lines of the character's face going completely black
like this clip of elsa that was sent in by vick hangar on
twitter
oh my god imagine being a kid she scared at least 10 kids
that shit's so fucking freaky there's like a disney version
there's like a mickey mouse of that too oh my god all right
guys i'm done show you guys i hope you guys enjoyed uh i
hope i hope you guys enjoyed um me showing you all my some
of my favorite channels and videos it was like uh it was
definitely it was a lot of random videos a lot of random
channels this is what goes on in my mind it's been three
hours i know it's been really fun though fun it's not gonna
be a super common thing uh it's just a little like like i
guess like maybe like once every couple of months i do
something like this uh be a be a really bad react to andy uh
sad they give the five gifted subs they could thank you to
be fair it's because like a lot of these videos and channels
i've seen both i've like this is literally like some of my
favorite channels and videos so like i've seen all these
videos already
You dragoons react to it.
You know how people who suggest favorite moments, like
favorite TV shows, and they watch your reaction to your
favorite part in the show?
That was me throughout the stream.
I was like, oh my God, this part, I'm gonna look at chat
now, see how they react to it.
but it was really fun to see your reactions to some of my
favorite videos and channels.
Phoenix, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
chat reacts to it's not streamer reacts to it's chat reacts
to um you were the react andy all along um bam thank you for
the reset for three months thank you thank you yeah i'm
farming you guys for reactions chat uh but yes i had a lot
of fun i had so much fun showing you guys some of my
favorite videos and channels and i hope you guys had a lot
of fun too everybody for those who are new here is Doki Bird
and I usually stream on YouTube so please check me out on
YouTube and subscribe to me over there and actually be a
real fan not like me because I accidentally exposed myself
as not subscribing to some of my favorite channels but
you'll do better right you're you guys will do better than
me uh many thank you for a thousand bitties thank you thank
you again thank you for the tier one sub thank you thank you
but I had so much fun though uh Celeste Silla Star, thank
you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, if you guys want to follow me on Twitter,
exclamation point Twitter, I usually tweet out when I'm
doing Twitch streams, because my Twitch streams are very,
are like, sort of rare.
But I let people know in advance on Twitter, so please
follow me over there.
If you want to support me via other means, please check out
my merch, exclamation point merch, and support me by buying
merch as well.
uh anyway guys i had a great time with everybody uh i'm
gonna head out now and as always everyone stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you stood up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye